es gibt ja noch etwas was mich immer
sehr stark beschäftigt und das ist meist
der öffentlich rechtliche rundfunk aber
heute morgen habe ich gedacht es wäre
satire ich habe gedacht das ist
irgendwie an böhmermann der jemand
angestellt hat um das wissensmagazin
quarks nachzumachen aber bevor ich ist
jetzt nach erzähle bilder sagen mehr als
tausend worte schauen wir doch mal in
diesen beitrag vom wissensmagazin vom
bdr rhein
und der überraschungssieger ist ja wir
waren auch überrascht die fdp wenn sie
ihre pläne tatsächlich durchzieht und 12
preis für alles macht dann wird die
kohlekraftwerke ganz schnell stillgelegt
werden und der klimaneutralität werden
wir sehr schnell sehr viel näher aber
wir bezweifeln dass sie das auch so tun
würde denn auch die fdp will
wahrscheinlich nicht dass deutschland
einen stromversorgungs problem bekommt
damit bewegt sich die fdp wohl
eigentlich eher auf dem vorletzten platz
was den klimaschutz angeht denn der co2
preis ist die einzige konkrete maßnahme
also sie sehen ich bin immer noch
schockiert ich habe es heute fünf mal
angeschaut dieses video der macht
einfach der wdr wahlkampf anders kann
man es nicht bezeichnen der wdr ist hier
zum bei kämpfer geworden und das
schlimmste ist es gibt im journalismus
zwei gattungen neutrale
berichterstattung kommentar hier hätte
ganz klar ein feld sein müssen mit
kommentar weil sie sagt ja die fdp würde
es nicht konkret ernst nehmen die fdp
würde es sich umsetzen und wuchs auf dem
unteren platz gerade noch vor der afg
geschafft was nicht ganz verstört ist
die fdp zum beispiel tritt dafür auch
einen technologieansätze zu nehmen jetzt
mit blick auf den klimawandel aber immer
in der diskussion geht es immer meistens
nur um die reduktion von co2 emissionen
wir haben aber drei ansätze um dem
klimawandel zu begegnen der erste ist
anpassung an höhere temperaturen der
zweite ist technologien wann wird man
über
sie sehen schon mir fällt schon schwer
ist auszusprechen diese technologie data
capture one reden wir darüber oder auch
über andere ansätze und das ist mein
ganz muss man aber das hier ist wirklich
ich habe mich gefragt was ich heute
anstelle von christian lender gemacht
hätte ich glaube ich hätte medienanwalt
1 ich weiß nicht was ich machen ich war
fassungslos gewesen und dafür zahlen wgz
gebührt wir werden ja noch gezwungen das
zu finanzieren das ist hier so
spektakuläre es gibt im fußball immer
die berühmte zitat wenn es mal nicht so
gut beim club läuft dann sagte er die
tabelle lügt nicht also das gilt für den
wdr offensichtlich nicht ich würde mir
das wünschen dass diese möglichkeit
bestehen würde auch in der
fußball-bundesliga dann hätten wir den
fc bayern münchen nicht immer auf platz
eins sondern würden ihn einfach wegen
irgendwelchen gründen einfach aus der
champions league raus und das ist mit
verlaub was die kollegen da gemacht
haben natürlich nicht sauber würden so
werd ich's richtig dann auch verstanden
habe setzen sie nur bei der fdp
offensichtlich maßstäbe an diese bei den
anderen nicht angesetzt haben und dann
künstlich die darunter zu setzen ist
natürlich frappierend sie haben es nicht
geändert
denn wenn man online artikel noch zu
diesem video bei dass und da haben sie
alle parteien bewertet als wahlanalyse
und da werden alle runter gesetzt also
alle würden zu wenig für die umwelt
machen bestehen übrigens gar nicht
sondern schlechter wäre sonst auf 1
trotzdem die grünen weil die sind ja
noch am nächsten
also irgendwie
mit dem herrn mit dem abstieg der lp auf
den vorletzten wohl hat er dann
plötzlich die linkspartei ganz vorne
ausrede die partei die sed erben wir
erinnern uns an die bilder aus der ddr
89 als die mauer fiel für alle die
vorher nicht in der ddr gewesen waren
was für ein umwelt paradies und ich
spreche jetzt wirklich gewohnt ist dass
es auch wirklich jeder merkt was ein
umwelt paradies die ddr war glaubt denn
ernsthaft jemand dass die linkspartei
auch mit ihrem wirtschaftsprogramm in
der lage wäre umweltstandards absurd zu
schaffen dass sie diesem land hier
gerecht werden glaubt doch kein mensch
ist eben das positive was über diesen
seiten ja natürlich wir brauchen
jetzt nicht im sondern ich muss etwas
positives über diesen beitrag sagen mit
diesem beitrag sieht man doch einfach
wunderbar zur kenntlichkeit entstellt
wie dieses öffentlich rechtliche
fernsehen arbeitet ich meine das ist ja
sozusagen ein meilenstein in der
weltgeschichte der unseriosität meine
diese
präsentatorin hat er da das er läutet
den fdp in so und so und dann hat sie
gesagt ja aber da die das ja dann
sowieso nicht machen
22 das tun werden also das ist ja dass
das lustigste
fragwürdigste abstrus ist der kriterium
dass man da anwenden kann und das zeigt
einfach die totale
ideologische durch solche und
wissentlich level und sie probiert aber
für noch geht in der schweiz glaube ich
dass
die sendung hat den anspruch ist finde
ich auch wichtig ist es eine wissens
sendung quarks die dafür steht
geschehnisse aus politik und
zeitgeschichte nein sorgen und
evidenzbasierten für uns doch diese
beitrag einzuholen wenn wir sehen wie
das funktioniert das merkt jeder dass
das hinten und vorne nicht sehr groß ist
dann sieht man einfach also wenn das
öffentlich rechtliche fernsehen auch in
anderen bereichen etwas ändert dann ist
das einfach durch drängt mit den
politischen positionen und leiten
chancenlosen es gibt ja auch alles ist
ja auch belegt das gibt die umfrage
unter den volontären feld erinnern sie
sich auch war sicherlich auch großes
thema in der schweiz ende letzten jahres
92 prozent der ard volontäre da sind ja
wdr volontärinnen und volontäre mit
dabei sind für rot rot grün gut sind
also ich finde das auch sehr sehr
problematisch mir ist neutralität sehr
sehr wichtig um im journalismus und um
der glaubwürdigkeit sehen ich finde es
bei ihnen total interessant weil sie
seien ja journalist und politiker wie
halten sie es da kann man da neutral
bericht erstatten wenn man politiker ist
ganz klar für eine richtung steht ja gut
also neutrale berichterstattung ist ja
nicht unbedingt das kriterium also wenn
sie einen öffentlichen sie wenn sie ein
öffentlich-rechtliches medium sind also
vom steuerzahler finanziert dann haben
sie danach klappt es dann möglichst
neutral das geschehen abzubilden sollten
sie ihre persönliche meinungsäußerung
core dekorieren wenn sie im privaten
sektor sind wenn sie eine firma haben
die niemand obwohl viele zeitungen von
ihrem muss so gemacht dann können sie
natürlich ihre vorlieben bringen aber
ich bin tatsächlich auch politiker und
journalist aber ich habe meine
überzeugung engagiere mich dafür aber
ich lasse in meiner zeitung alle
möglichen meinungen zu wasser von links
bis rechts ich habe meine meinung aber
als journalist unterliege ich auch eine
professionalität geboten was die hier
macht das ist ja auch ein mangel an
professionalität weil die argumentation
dass ihr nicht nur die frage und haben
einen kommentar aus man aussagen nicht
auf eine analyse und es ist nicht nur
die frage der neutralität hier sondern
es ist auch die frage der
professionalität weil diese
argumentation also wie sie die ach die
fdp darunter mit der begründung weil sie
sehen dass wir zwei aus
dass der beitrag nicht gelungen ist ja
ich finde einfach nicht genug oder
verwerflich dabei das also dann auch
einfach nicht in ordnung ist und man
neutral sein muss öffentlich rechtlichen
aber ich finde eben das ist im
journalismus sowie so der anspruch außer
ist steht kommentar dabei ganz klar
neutral zu sein und so was natürlich
extrem traurig für unseren gesamten
berufsstand
[Musik]